what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and i'm back with 10 more things
you didn't know about eldon ring you
know the drill let's get into it george
rr martin this is a fun one that was
actually pointed out to me in the
comments by haitani it's common
knowledge that elden ring's backstory
was written by george r.r martin so it
was the culmination of two creative
titans with hidetaka miyazaki using this
as a base
and as we all know from dark souls 1
with gwen gwyndolin and gwynevere
hidetaka miyazaki loves reusing names
for families in elton ring these major
groupings are the god family which
includes godwin godfrey and godric or ji
the r family which includes radigan
ranala and ronnie renna or r and the
valkyrie family which includes america
mckellar melania and millicent or m in
other words these major families are grm
or george rr martin pretty cool
killing melana and speaking of people
whose name starts with the letter m
i know i'm a king of transitions let's
talk about melana melana offers to act
as your maiden if you'll take her to the
foot of the herd tree and as your only
interactions with her are from appearing
at slice of grace seems like that's it
but prisa gaming channel found and
posted a way to set up a trap to kill
her
and as it turns out she has quite the
intricate death animation where grace
shoots out of her and it looks like an
urgery seems to form
it has major lore implications i'm not
going to go into here and honestly i
haven't tested this yet myself so for
now i'm going to trust this as a
legitimate animation as the game is so
new gatekeeper go stock the secret thief
when you play through stormville castle
you may notice anytime you die and
return to get your runes some of them
are
missing so why is that it may seem like
a quirk of the legacy dungeons but no
other legacy dungeon has that effect
well this is something patrick o'toole
pointed out to me in the comments as it
turns out gatekeeper gostok is an
[ __ ] i mean he seems so nice right
trying to help you out and get you to
take the backside of the castle to reach
godric the grafted i would advise
against taking the main gate into the
castle
it's tightly guarded but when you defeat
gadrik and he's stomping on godric's
head
something might seem a little off and
i'm not talking about stopping on godric
we just killed him and i think we can
forgive gostok for not being fond of his
employer i can do whatever takes my
fancy well as it turns out anytime you
died in stormville castle gatekeeper
gestak was stealing at 30 percent of
your runes the only way to get them back
is by killing a stock prior to beating
godric in which case you'll get your
runes back and also prove he was
stealing them from you
if you kill gustak after defeating
godric you won't get those runes back
what a sneaky thief vare lover of roses
the very first npc you'll meet in elton
ring is varay who you meet right next to
the first step sight of grace vary seems
a little bit off but he doesn't really
do anything bad to you so there's
probably no reason to attack him right
wrong
attack him
for the lore if you do vary will respond
by attacking back with the bouquet of
roses that causes bleed damage this is
actually doubly interesting for one vary
is actually a member of the bloody
fingers and worshiper of the lord of
blood so you know bleed damage makes
sense for him for two eventually he'll
leave this spot and as he lets you know
he's left for the rose church
so i guess we know where he got his
bouquet as the rose church is filled
with blood roses he doesn't have to be
so mean when he tries to give it to you
those thorns hurt vary lover of invaders
continuing with vary for chatting with
him at the rose church and telling him
you find the two fingers suspicious
he'll agree with you and give you five
festering bloody fingers which allows
you to invade other players he then will
continuously encourage you to try them
out so if you want to continue vary's
quest line you'll have to do just this
you'll now have to successfully use
three festering fingers to invade other
players although you don't actually need
to win for these to count if you invade
another player's game and they leave for
a boss chamber booting you out it still
counts if you lose to another player it
still counts
damn you rukia
and of course if you win that counts too
now chat with vary again asks to be
anointed and he'll give you a cloth he
wants you to soak in a maiden's blood to
do this you'll have to return all the
way back to the chapel of anticipation
which you can find by teleporting at the
four belfries where you can soak your
cloth in the blood of the already dead
maiden from the very beginning of the
game or what may be easier is you can
also head to the dead maiden you found
at the church of inhibition located here
on a map she's the same maiden you'll
have been able to receive the finger
maiden set from for completing this
quest you'll receive the lord of blood's
exaltation this unique item will warp
you into the special location i won't
spoil here if you use it but don't worry
there's another way to get there i again
won't spoil in this particular episode
point is though you don't need to do
this invasion questline if you don't
want to in order to reach the location
kicking let's go back to the basics in
dark souls 1 kicking was a super
important mechanic if an enemy had their
shield up kick them to open them up and
then attack however this mechanic seems
to be missing from eldon ring or is it
this time around there's an ash of war
that will let you kick if you have
nothing equipped you'll be able to kick
with l2 or if you have the right ash of
war a kick it is and it works the exact
same way you'll be able to kick away an
enemy with a shield and then get in a
visceral attack but
at what price
fears curse blessing early on in elden
ring you'll be given the opportunity to
enter the roundtable hold a site where
many of the game's npcs gather to hang
out and chill maybe they want to pour
over a book maybe they want to quietly
hang out next to a door until they are
assigned a secret mission or maybe they
want to endlessly smith weapons for
lowly tarnish because they're chained
and actually they're forced to do this
for eternity and maybe i just assumed
they wanted to do this
because i'm a jerk like that well
another npc you'll find here is the
deathbed companion thea she just wants
to give you a sweet hug so why not
well
i'll tell you why not when fear tells
you this perhaps you might share with me
some of your lifely figure she literally
means this for hugging her you'll get
the baldicon's blessing and a status
effect that will give you a debuff of
minus five percent of your max hp for
the entire time you have baldicon's
blessing in your inventory if you ever
wonder what the little icon up there
meant that's what it is your hp debuff
but don't worry if you want to get rid
of the status effect all you have to do
is use balikin's blessing and bam
it's gone really though you should chat
with fia because it will progress an
important storyline for one of the
game's potential endings just make sure
to remember to use balikin's blessing if
you want to get rid of that debuff
blythe's mask blythe is one of my
favorite characters in elden ring he's
basically guts from berserk but
permanently in wolf form and you can be
just like him by finding the black wolf
mask a mask an assassin made to look
like blive in order to try to reach and
kill ronnie to find the black wolf mask
you'll need to head to selivus's rise
this is located at three sisters behind
karia manor and to the south of ronnie's
rise head up the ladder past elvis head
out onto the balcony and then instead of
climbing up the stairs jump onto the
wall that surrounds the rise
from here you can walk over and pick up
the black wolf mask progressing
blackguard blackguard seems like a bit
of a jerk he just sits around cooking
and eating his prawns all the meanwhile
stealing ryan's necklace which you can
purchase from him for 1 000 runes to
return to her but did you know you can
make blackguard open up to you and
actually become pretty friendly towards
you all you have to do is buy super
overpriced quick prawns from him if you
do so he'll recognize a fellow prawn
lover in you and open up he'll even
admit that he's not a great guy
makes no bloody sense anyway
why some no name [ __ ] like me should
get called to the lands between no it
doesn't blackguard
no it does not pausing the game did you
know that you can pause elton ring the
game is meant to be played with no
pausing allowed but we're going to get
around that and yes even while you're in
the middle of combat press pause to go
to your menu enter into your inventory
then go to menu explanation in the
inventory screen and bam
game is paused of course you might get
attacked and die while you're trying to
do this but at least it's available for
you if you really
truly need it and that wraps up this
edition of 10 things you didn't know i
hope you learned something new and if
not i'll have another episode for you
next week let me know if there's
something you found as i'm having an
absolute blast finding out new minor
mechanics and questlines i missed until
next time peace
you